but at the end of here what we do is we
do a an email question and it's called
unhelpful advice you can be helpful or
not helpful and then we answer them okay
okay a helpful advice with Bobby
kalila at Sue Tripoli what's up everyone
my name is Edgar and I love you do that
second city oh man thousand voices no
just one but yeah my name is Edgar and I
love each and one of ever you I'm 28 and
I'm from New Mexico and I need some
advice a few months ago after me and my
wife had done a lot five plus years of
roleplay with wife sharing we decided to
actually try it out she ended up having
sex with two other guys at different
times the main reason we did it is
because I'm only average-sized at best
and she has given birth to two kids and
she said she just wanted to try
something different and I was really
aroused by the idea of watching her too
so I found guys and set it up however
after the first encounter my wife became
extra aroused
we went from sex once weekly to everyday
and she wanted to keep having sex with
well-endowed men every day if she could
after the second encounter we had a long
convoluted my size she ends up telling
me that she kuba can't feel me and just
wants to hurry up and finish every time
I always felt she faked her interest but
not to that point we stopped the sharing
after the second encounter because I
said it was time-consuming and she
didn't want to look for herself that's
the main question over however now she
isn't as aroused and we have sex less
than weekly and she is back to faking
interest and kind of over the over the
top about it what should I do
I love my wife they're married they're
married over I love my wife and I've
talked to her about it but she assures
me she enjoys it now thanks in advance
she lying that's a weird thing dog Edgar
that's a weird thing opened up a door
yeah you shouldn't open that's what
people don't understand it's like I
always have my this happened to my
friend he's like yeah I was in this open
relationship and guys think that's great
man it's like hey dude you know I get to
go bang some wall but you know what dog
you're a girl gets
bang diggy guess what man there's a lot
more dicks banging on that door than
[ __ ] girls banging on your door and
like you open that [ __ ] thing now
personally I understand [ __ ] holding
chuckling I understand it you've been in
relationship for a while you got a
decision to make yeah ah do you want to
get a divorce where you lose all your
[ __ ] the house you're paying for move
the [ __ ] out yeah can you let your wife
get some strange on the side I get that
yeah it's an easy decision for me yeah
yeah who you would do it then dude if
I'm into a relationship I I'm in a
relation in a long relationship now you
are yeah but it's a miracle he could say
the same about you Bobby I've always
been a relationship [ __ ] man but
never longer than like a year and it
doesn't matter I'm a relationship guy
he's never one he's like I am gay what's
her name thirteen years yeah what's her
name Dana anyways back to the story
anyways I'm thinking like if she
listened to see a list of my PI I don't
know dude I don't think I don't think
you can go back yeah no I mean like it's
just the truth but you know what dude
girls fake orgasm guys fake feelings so
I mean we both bring sometimes some
fake-ass [ __ ] to it and we just keep
this facade up for a while but it sounds
like you've I mean I think he should
[ __ ] try to find his own weird thing
he's into you know but maybe the kook
thing is his weird thing he probably
enjoys it more than he's admitting maybe
he's just upset because she moans
different than when he when he's with
her I also think like I don't know I
don't think I mean women in general when
we're into somebody and we love them we
really don't care how big they are we
care about it in a sex
since we're okay yeah but that's a very
small portion of our lives together that
is like I mean sex is really overblown
like we act like I talk about it's like
it's really your sex in what you're into
is about some as important as your
workout like you talk a lot of game
about your workout you know same thing
about sex you're like I'm gonna go to
the [ __ ] gym I'm gonna do karate
I love Pilates and then you end up just
hanging out drinking a smoothie at the
fruit ball yeah it's the same [ __ ]
thing we're working out you're like babe
I'm gonna [ __ ] tie you up I'm gonna
put this right thing put wax your nipple
put a horse tail [ __ ] butt plug it
yeah and then it's like pump pump dump
right yeah it have to be so much more
than it really yeah I'm having sex every
day that's still seven minutes out of 24
hours all day that's such a small
portion of your life but it's just weird
so you give a little you take a little I
don't know man I think it is I think his
wife needs to take acting lessons and
act
dude that's that's it but get Meisner
Klein is my or what it does about this
does would you do Juvenal work agile
rejuvenation why don't they just go and
go to sort of give me a 12 year old save
the hair tighten that [ __ ] eyes I have
to get wrecked before the rejuvenator
can you be like can I just like that
like click click and like make it
tighter
I suspect that she's like a rostering in
their pouch
you know Debbie gray you have a
drawstring and then the guy can just
adjust it yeah size fits all now the
baby's bad you yeah but also now that I
know that he's allowing to me having sex
with other men why would I give him III
want to keep doing that so why would I
tell him he's giving me the most
pleasure do you know what I mean like if
I don't want to tell him he's a
one-stop-shop for all of my pleasures if
I know that he's allowing me to see
other men so as long as I tell him his
dick is insufficient he's gonna keep
letting me [ __ ] other men and she has to
make a decision what's more important
with her love or dick yeah if she if
it's love she's got
come to grips I mean but why should he
you have two kids you get lit she hasn't
given up to him and like fake it more
better and that he SP cooled her get
another dick and maybe enjoying it shoot
some [ __ ] porn up videos put her to
work and at some point you're both gonna
be old and decrepit and it's not gonna
matter yeah at some point you're just
like it's just like let's hope we like
the same TV show yeah
[Music]